hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play [ __ ] this game
now someone sent me an email this game
and they said that I just had to play it
and judging by the title I don't think
I'm gonna enjoy this very much
while also judging by the music and the
rather sickening art style art style
that they got going on in this game well
let's give it a try
what's the worst that could happen leap
hop hop prep wait prep press n dilip you
can land on the hurdles 50 points per
hurdle cleared end to start okay press
end to start why do I have to press end
to start okay this is strange what's
going on here I'm so confused okay so I
don't I don't need to wait what
bypass baby whoa wait my past baby poms
the bombs are babies why are the bombs
babies what do I need to press B okay
press B to move avoid the falling bombs
five points per second num is 50 if hit
what crispy this duck oh I gotta play
both oh okay well that makes so much
more sense okay so I'm just hopping
hurdles over here and press B - no
that's wrong
don't move there I almost got no I'm
it's a hurdle oh oh oh I'm beginning to
understand why there are so many empty
squares oh oh good good good
shoot ruin run ruin ready rebels what
was our to change direction attack the
alien ships oh my god this is not what I
wanted to do with my life okay hang on
wait no wait what press B n press R to
change direction why why is that a thing
wait a minute I missed a hurdle we know
are these points counted individually
per game or or what's the deal here is
that why I think are are just kind of
changes Direction wonder stupid even
devour delicious I don't know what
you're saying
our delicious dots Presby to changed
direction dyed your why wouldn't you
make them lit name of it to the letter
that I don't know whatever let's just go
let's just go for him in prison ve to
change what is that like a version a
snake or something I have no idea I'm
just gonna wait and V to go there we go
all right I'm just gonna press n at a
certain wait no oh yeah yeah yeah I'm
getting this cuz our can go on its own
and then I'm just gonna spastically know
Oh catch crashing crates press F oh my
god press F to catch cat crashing crates
F F F F F F F and F V V F F F F I've
given up on P n R I've just completely
given up I I don't think I can do that
at all Oh V is going out of control okay
F it's actually pretty good because V is
the only one that split blast bouncing
balls that's not a B that's an H or that
I don't even nevermind you know what I
don't care blast bouncing ball what the
hell is that what am i doing oh I'm
shooting a hug I gotta jump hang on I
got a blast he's bouncing balls use my I
made that hurdle got F going R and H
need to blast these balls into oblivion
no Jumbos pressing the button no I was
totally oh I got a blast those balls
shove probably push puck what probably
push buck and shove has nothing to do
with S or Y I don't know let's just go
what is that I have no idea what that is
I just got a spam H and what is what is
it what is y
I don't know what Y is I gotta just H H
it up as Oh V everything else has just
been abandoned at this point it's just H
and n that's all I can do and why I
don't even know how Y works bounce push
persistent pellets oh my god you know
what I'm just gonna spastically push
every button here until the game freakin
ends yeah you get back you pellets you
pellet bastards I'm oh my god oh my god
H is kind of going crazy the balls have
gone out of control I don't seem to have
any more stability anymore
the Mazda starting to consume my life I
can't grab it on the balls I gotta push
the pellet Oh
game over who's that at write that a
[ __ ] this game that [ __ ] it know what
[ __ ] that game now you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
alright so I was dumb and aggravating
and rage-inducing my blood pressures way
through the roof that was impossible how
in the world can you keep track of nine
eight whatever how many things there
were I don't know my brain does not work
that way I'm sorry
it just doesn't so anyway no thanks to
the guy who suggested this gig it's
terrible this game is bearable no I gave
pretty fun I could imagine myself trying
to meet this but not now so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye